(upbeat music)
Food, I love eating it, talking about it,
watching it on TV.
Here is some delicious kitchen inspiration.
(air whooshing)
Hi, Drew.
I'm Jessie, founder of Life As A Strawberry.
And today I'm teaching you
how to make my favorite simple cranberry sauce
for the holidays.
Start by adding 12 ounces of cranberries
to a small sauce pan with a bit of maple syrup and honey,
this is gonna help us balance out the tartness
of these cranberries.
Add a splash of water and the juice of one orange slice,
then tuck that orange right into the pot
along with everything else.
Add a pinch of salt and 1/2 of a cinnamon stick
for some great depth of flavor,
then stir it all up and cook over low heat
for 15 to 20 minutes, just until the cranberries
start to burst and break down.
Remove the orange slice and the cinnamon stick from the pot.
And if you don't love this chunky cranberry sauce,
you can use an immersion blender
to smooth it all out a little bit before you serve.
This is a great make-ahead recipe.
You can serve it immediately or let it cool
and stored in the fridge for up to a week
or the freezer for several months.
When you're ready to eat,
top with a bit of fresh orange zest and enjoy.
(air whooshing)
That recipe looks muah!
(lips smacking)
(upbeat music)